[Music]
for you
the influence of Burt Bacharach on
popular music is almost impossible to
measure
together with long time songwriting
partner Hal David he wrote dozens and
dozens of hits for scores of performers
in the 1960s and 70s
[Music]
they distilled a kind of sexy
sophisticated cocktail party vibe that
stood in sharp contrast to the rock and
roll of The Beatles And The Rolling
Stones
baccarat's collaborations with Dion
Warwick produced many hits
[Music]
now is
bell to answer
baccarat song one less bell to answer
performed by the fifth dimension's
Marilyn McCoo is arguably one of the
greatest torch songs of all time
sometimes bacharach's songs teetered on
the verge of saccharin sentimentality
but never crossed the line
just like me and they long to be close
to you
David wrote soundtracks for movies
notably Butch Cassidy and the Sundance
Kid in 1969. B.J Thomas sang Raindrops
Keep Falling on My Head they keep
falling they're heavy baccarat won the
Oscar for best original score his songs
also won Tony and Grammy Awards
Bacharach married four times including
to actress Angie Dickinson
[Music]
he continued to perform at the piano
well into his later years
he will be remembered for as long as his
Lush romantic Works float on the breeze
of moonlit Knights
[Music]